federal health officials are warning
this morning not to eat any romaine
lettuce unless you know where it's
coming from
as the e.coli outbreak spreads across
the country the CDC advisory now
includes whole heads and hearts of
romaine lettuce along with chopped and
bagged romaine CBS News confirms at
least 64 people were infected in 16
states but while the government believes
that the lettuce is from the Yuma
Arizona region it doesn't know who grew
supplied or distributed distributed
rather the contaminated vegetables
and/or iner shows us how victims are
responding and I was at a salad place
ordered letter at ordered a salad for
the first time asked where is the
lettuce from just to be safe I got
arugula because I was still well that's
the thing how do you know where your
lettuce from and do you know the CDC
says it can take an average of three to
four days after coming into contact for
people with e.coli to start feeling
symptoms we spoke with one teenager who
says she thought she had a stomach bug
it was a scary process
Mia's leuco is a high school dancer who
enjoys eating healthy foods like salads
but after eating a romaine salad from a
local store in Pennsylvania she started
throwing up and having abdominal issues
it's kind of hard to sit there in a
hospital and not know what's wrong with
you and you feel so like drained after
four days in the hospital she says
doctors told her she might be suffering
from an autoimmune disease but just as
she was heading home all the doctors
came in and it was kind of like a big
surprise like it's he cool her mother
Tina we were all shocked it was such a
relief at least 64 people in 16 states
have been infected with the same strand
of e.coli linked to romaine lettuce
about half have been hospitalized the
CDC says most people develop symptoms
like diarrhea severe stomach cramps and
vomiting and recover within a week but
five people have suffered from a form of
kidney failure what's concerning me at
this point is there's an unusually high
hospitalization rate Bill Marler is a
food safety lawyer representing Louise
Frazier she's suing Panera Bread saying
she contracted ecoli after eating
romaine lettuce at one of their
restaurants in New Jersey and as a
result was hospitalized for weeks
she says she was diagnosed with a type
of
any failure which required several blood
transfusions
she's now suing both the restaurant and
its supplier of fresh way Foods Inc the
restaurant the grocery store is
responsible for the food they sell you
and if it is contaminated with a
pathogen it's defective and the chain of
distribution that supplied that is
ultimately responsible Panera Bread
officials told us they don't comment on
pending litigation
but said they have resupplied with
romaine from other regions supplier
fresh wave foods has not responded to
our request for comment it can be pretty
frustrating for consumers when they've
heard since 2011 that new food safety
standards are going to be in place
Sandra askin is the director of food
safety at the Pew Charitable Trusts she
says investigators will try to trace the
romaine lettuce back to the farm where
it could have been contaminated by
bacteria through irrigation water
animals fertilizer and more the romaine
also could have been cross contaminated
in a processing facility while it's
being cut washed and bagged Eskin says
it's challenging to pinpoint the exact
cause we know the problem was a coli
contamination where did it come from how
did it get on the lettuce once that's
determined we can figure out if some of
the regulations need to be tweaked for
now the CDC is telling consumers if they
can't confirm the source of romaine
lettuce to not buy it eat it and to
throw it away
Consumer Reports is advising people to
avoid all romaine lettuce because they
say it's unrealistic to expect consumers
to figure out whether their romaine was
produced in Arizona
Tina's love Co says she's glad she kept
searching for answers for her daughter's
illness had we not gone back to the
doctor and then gone to the emergency
room she could have gotten much sicker
very quickly well doctors say Mia should
make a full recovery the produce
industry groups say they're cooperating
fully with the government to identify
the source of this outbreak and that the
health and safety of their consumers is
of the utmost importance but they say
that the harvest and shipment of romaine
from the Yuma Arizona region has been
stopped but for now the word is
no romaine unless you are absolutely
sure you know where it came from
a lot of people got sick from eating in
restaurants well what are you gonna do
ask yes and as you point out you still
don't know where it comes from even when
you ask right you know you have no
guarantee that it didn't come from
Arizona right so hopefully they'll track
that down the cause on this quickly yes
yeah just put a pause on your deep
affection for Romain Caesar to spinach
this week Anna thank you